تظاهر انصار المعارضه في اسرائيل في
احتجاجات متواصله على التعديلات التي
ادخلها الائتلاف الحاكم على النظام
القضائي والتي ترى فيها المعارضه خطرا
سيحول اسرائيل الى ما وصفوها بدكتاتوريه
دينيه واعتقلت اشرطه الاسرائيليه 12 شخصا
بينما بدا متظاهرون في التجمع وسط تل ابيب
واغلقوا شوارع فرعيه وقد كشفت السلطات
الامنيه من حضورها لكن ذلك لم يمنع
المتظاهرين من اغلاق شارع ايالون الرئيسي
الذي يربط تل ابيب بالقدس كما استخدمت
الشرطه فرق الخياله لتفريق المتظاهرين
ومنعهم من الوصول الى الشارع الرئيسي
وحاول المتظاهرون اغلاق شوارع رئيسيه في
مدن اخرى مثل القدس وحيفا الا ان الشرطه
فرقتهم
وعلى الرغم من هذه الاحتجاجات المستمره
منذ اسابيع صدقت الهيئه العامه للكنيسه
الاسرائيلي صباحا اليوم على مشروع قانون
يشدد من شروط عزل رئيس الحكومه او اعلان
عجله عن القيام بمهامه ويمنح القانون
الحصانه لبنيامين نتنياهو الذي يحاكم بتهم
الفساد وخيانه الامانه وقد صوت لمشروع
القانون 61 نائبا وعرضه سبعه واربعون
وقال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه يعتزم المضي قدما في اصلاحات
قضائيه مسؤوله حسب وصفه معتبرا ان
الاصلاحات القضائيه ستوازن بين السلطات
وستحافظ على حقوق الاقليه واتهم نتنياهو
ممثلين معارضه برفض الدخول في مفاوضات منذ
اشهر
ان الطريقه الامثل لتحقيق الاصلاحات
المتوازنه ومنع الشرخ في اوساط الشعب هي
المباحثات وتوصلوا الى توافق واسع قدر
الامكان للاسف حتى الان ممثل المعارضه
رفضوا الجلوس معنا واجراء مباحثات لقد تمت
اضاعه اربعه اشهر تقريبا امل ان يتغير ذلك
وان يتغير ذلك في الايام القادمه انا اعمل
من اجل تحقيق حل وانا اصغي لمخاوف الطرف
الاخر
اضاف نتنياهو ان الدعوات لعصيان الاوامر
العسكريه تشكل خطرا على الامن القومي
لاسرائيل وعلى الامن الشخصي للافرادي كذلك
ويجب ان تتوقف وفق تعبيره
اجتمعت اليوم مع عدد من الوزراء منهم وزير
الدفاع واستمعت اليه فيما يتعلق بالمخاوف
وتداعيات الوضع على الامن القومي لاسرائيل
انا اخذ ذلك بعين الاعتبار وفي ان معا اجد
لزاما علي ان اكرر مره اخرى الا مجال
لعصيان الاوامر العسكريه العصيان يشكل
خطرا على الامن القومي الاسرائيلي وعلى
الامن الشخصي لكل فرد منا ولا يوجد مبرر
للعصيان سوف ابذل كل ما في وسعي من اجل
تهدئه الخواطر والتئام الشرخ بين مكونات
الشعب لاننا اخوه
هذا وقال رئيس الشباك ان اسرائيل تمضي في
طريق خطير للغايه بوجود تهديدات امنيه
وتواصل الاحتجاجات الشعبيه حديث ياتي بعد
اتهام زعيم المعارضه يئير لبيد نتنياهو
بتجاهل وزير دفاعه ومعلومات استخباريه
مهمه وصلت الى مكتبه
في تغريده على تويتر للاستماع لاصوات مئات
الالاف ممن وصفهم بالوطنيين المخلصين
الذين نزلوا للشوارع اضاف انه بدلا من وقف
التشريع وتهدئه الاجواء يستمرون نتنياهو
في نشر ما وصفها اكاذيب الشائله ضد نظام
العداله التي لا علاقه لها بالواقع بحسب
تعبيره كما طالب لبيد قاده في الحزب
الحاكم بالانشقاق
من القدس معنا مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الياس ضعن في صوره هذا السجال الدائر بين
نتنياهو المعارضه من جهه وبين مكونات
الحكومه نفسها ايضا
بالفعل اليوم بني مريتانيا يشعر نفسه بانه
اصبح اكثر قوه لاداره دفه هذه الاصلاحات
لاسيما وانه ممنوع بقرار من المستشار
القضائيه للحكومه بالتدخل بهذه الاصلاحات
القضائيه على ضوء ما يلاحقه من تهم فساد
لكن بعد التحصين نفسه والتعديلات التي
ادخلها على هذا القانون يقول بانه هو الان
سيدخل بقوه على خط هذه المواجهه ما بين
المعارضه والائتلاف الحاكم في كل ما يتعلق
بهذه الاصلاحات القضائيه وهو من يدير
امورها وهو يؤكد بان حكومته ماضيه في هذه
الاصلاحات رغم كل هذه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
في اسرائيل وان هذه
الاصلاحات هدفها احداث التوازن ما بين
السلطات في اسرائيل وهو يقول بانه سيسعى
الى تحصين حقوق الاقليه في اسرائيل ضمن
هذه الاصلاحات ماض في تشريع ربما احق احد
اهم البنود في هذه الاصلاحات كما يسميها
او التغييرات التي تقول المعارضه بانها
انقلاب على نظام الحكم في اسرائيل وهي
التعديلات التي يريد نتنياهو ادخالها في
لجنه تعيين القضاه بحيث تكون الغلبه في
بين اعضائها لصالح الائتلاب بمعنى ان هذه
اللجنه سوف تكون لجنه مسيسه وتابعه
للحكومه الاسرائيليه وهذا ما ترفضه
المعارضه جمله وتفصيرا لكن من يمينه يقول
بان هذا القانون سيطره على الكنيسه
الاسبوع المقبل وسيجري التصويت عليه وهو
يقول بانه يفتح الباب على مصراعيه في
المحاكم امام شرائح مختلفه في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي كانت ابواب المحاكم مغلقه
وموصده في في وجههم لكن من ناحيه اخرى
المعارضه تقول بان هذه اكاذيب لا تنطلي
عليهم هم يريدون اولا ان توقف الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على الفور كل الاجراءات
التشريعيه في الكنيست من اجل الجلوس على
طاوله المفاوضات وربما البحث عن ما هو
يمكن التوفيق ما بين الطرفين وان كانت
الطريق بعيده والاراء والمواقف متباعده
للغايه ما بين الائتلاف والمعارضه في
رؤيتهم لهذه التغييرات ولهذه الاصلاحات
هناك من يقول انه من المستحيل ان يلتقي
الطرفان على في منتصف الطريق على الاقل من
اجل التوصل الى تسويه تكون مرضيه للطرفين
لاسيما بعد ان رفضت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
منحى الرئيس الاسرائيلي الذي حاول ان يقرب
وجهات النظر بين الطرفين شكرا لك
مراسلنا من القدس